what is the Friendship Paradox the
Friendship Paradox is this phenomenon in
which uh your friends have more friends
than you do uh your sex partners have
more sex partners than you do your
Twitter followers have or ex your ex-f
followers have more uh followers than
you do and it's a it's a paradox because
it seemingly doesn't make sense you how
can your friends have more friends than
you on average and many uh many of your
listeners especially I think will be
familiar with this sort of Paro
phenomena that you know a
disproportionate uh number of of awards
go to a small number of people a
disproportionate uh uh amount of money
goes to a small percentage of people as
well but this also works in the social
realm so you the example that I gave in
uh recent substack post is to imagine
you have keep it easy you have 10
friends and uh three of your friends are
kind of like you you know just kind of
an average person with an average social
life uh you have three friends who are
shut inss who maybe don't go out that
much but you have another friend who is
a super connector and has 100 or 150 or
maybe even a thousand friends I mean
some people who who are just sort of
very social super extroverted in that
99th percentile and so when you average
this across all 10 of your friends uh
they they may have you know on average
20 plus friends while you have 10 and so
it sort of at first class it doesn't
make sense but then you know when you
when you sort of break it down
mathematically it does and this is why
there's that that Paradox and then same
with sex partners you know maybe you've
had five or 10 or 20 sex partners but
one of those people may have had 100
plus and so when you average that out
your sex partners have had more sex
partners than you and then same with
Twitter followers right like you know
maybe uh one of your followers has you
know a million plus well you have 10,000
or something average that out the math
still um shaks out in the same way the
example that I I also gave in that essay
is uh you know when when Warren Buffett
walks into an auditorium everyone
becomes a Millionaire on average right
and it's the same kind of idea here so
yeah and what's the implication
psychologically for people with that is
that felt sense at all cuz obviously
it's uh kind of anti-typical to what you
would expect this is all a surprise to
everyone to find out that if Warren
Buffett's in the local post code that
they've just become an honorary
millionaire for the most Jud
mathematics is there some sort of sense
by which people are are conscious of
this sort of thing I know that Gad sad
in his most recent book talks about uh
the best sort of people to be friends
with the people who are having a little
bit less sex than
you right yeah yeah I I remember that I
remember that from from his book well
yeah so so I think that we we we fall
prey to um so so in that the classic
psychology book Thinking Fast and Slow
Daniel conman coined this term what you
see is all there is uh and we pay
attention to what's visible what's right
in front of us the the knowns but we
don't necessarily pay much attention to
the the known unknowns the things that
that aren't in our immediate uh line of
vision and so with with the Friendship
Paradox we will pay a lot of attention
to the most extroverted people they're
very visible they enjoy often being very
visible extroverted people tend to be
that way they update their social media
Pages a lot uh when you they're they're
more likely to uh text you and then be
responsive to your texts and more likely
to to to meet up with you and then tell
you about their uh uh Adventures hiking
in the Himalayas or how they just got
back from this country or uh just got
done speaking at at this event and so
forth and so you're listening to this
person and and for many people they may
hear this and think like wow everyone
out there is doing all of these great
things and you know here I am sort of
working my 95 or just you know sort of
living
a normal ordinary life and uh and many
people uh will report feeling sort of um
uh diminished socially uh and this is an
interesting phenomenon here because
there's a ton of research in social
psychology on this idea called the
better than average effect uh and the
better than average effect or the
elusory superiority effect as it's
sometimes called essentially that we
tend to uh uh believe ourselves to be
better than others there's this sort of
self-enhancement that goes on so when
you ask um people are are you you know
are you smarter than average are you a
better driver than average it's like 75%
of people believe that they're a better
than average driver ex yeah exactly uh
uh you know there's there's res in
Academia to you you know you ask
students are you a you know a better
student than average ask professors are
you a better teacher than average and
yeah exactly 70 80 plus percent say
they're better than the average person
uh in all these domains um and yet um
there's fascinating work on related to
the Friendship Paradox that we tend to
have a sort of characteristically dismal
view of our social lives so there have
been a couple of studies now in which
you they ask participants uh you know do
you do you go to more a fewer parties
than others do you see your family more
or less than others do you have more a
fewer friends than others do you eat
alone more or less than others and
generally speaking people think that
they are uh sort of less socially
connected they have fewer friends they
eat alone more they go to fewer parties
and this is an inversion of the illusory
superiority complex right we sort of
have at least in the social realm a
lesser than average average effect
rather than the better than average
effect and and this is related to that
friendship Paradox and that um that sort
of what you see as all there is uh the
way the researchers explain this is that
um again so so you you when you think to
yourself well do I go to more a fewer
parties than others well you know when I
see other people at parties and I'm not
at a party and uh you know I see my
family you know x amount of times a year
but then when I pull up social media and
I see people you know taking selfies
with their dad or whatever um or their
mom or their sister and so you see all
of these and then you start to think
well you know I'm not with my family
right now when I saw that photo and so
you uh sort of easily sort of fall prey
to this idea that well everyone out
there is taking these selfies and having
a good time and going home and and um
and you're not and you're not paying
attention to the people who aren't with
their families uh you know one of the
lines I use in that post sort of
summarizing This research is no one is
taking uh photos and posting them online
when they're eating lunch alone or when
they're binge watching a TV show or when
they're just having an off day and just
need some time to decompress and be
alone for a while M they're not you know
uploading a video or taking photos of
themselves we tend to take photos when
we're being social when we're being
exactly the peak experiences and and uh
I know you you you've talked about this
before about uh what is it comparing uh
uh you know your blooper real to
everyone else's highlight re corre
something like that and so we do that
and then we tend to think like everyone
else is sort of at the party without you
uh there's a nice line uh in one of the
papers that I site the researchers you
know sort of sort of um painting a
picture of what this might look like of
a student in in a college dorm room uh
maybe doing their homework being a
diligent student and they hear a party
going on upstairs and you hear all the
lights and all the music and everything
and it sounds like everyone's up there
and you're thinking wow I'm the only one
here doing my doing my homework but
you're not you know of course you're not
hearing all of the other students uh in
that dorm room as well doing their
homework they're making any noise right
so this is what you see is all there is
or what you hear is all there is and so
that person is sitting there thinking
everyone is at the party without me when
this isn't the case um it's just you
happen to be hearing the people who are
at the party not the people who aren't
so there's uh this is very much due to
the visibility of particular types of
social experiences that is now
facilitated by being online right right
I learned about the 1% rule okay from
you okay go through that I feel like
that's related here this is the 1% rule
on the internet and it's you know it's
this isn't Empirical research but this
is just a sort of shorthand way of
understanding how uh how social media
Works how the internet works now
uh and the basic idea is that uh online
1% of Internet users uh are creators
they're the ones out there producing the
videos and the podcasts and the the
written content and all the things that
we're sort of consuming when we pull up
on our phones and then 9% of Internet
users are uh are commenters they're
engaging with the content in some way
maybe they're uh reposting or retweeting
or liking or commenting they're the ones
who sort of uh want to engage with the
content in some way maybe they're not uh
uh original content uh producer users
but they do like to sort of uh make
themselves visible by by uh by being
commenters and so on and then 90% of
people are just lurkers the people that
we aren't seeing the people who are just
sort of passively scrolling their phones
or uh uh you know looking at your
looking at your stuff listening to it
reading it but they're not um they're
not engaging with it in the same way and
I think a lot of you know so I'm I'm a
substack or you're a podcaster I think a
lot of content producers 1% they be yeah
ex the 1% but we pay a lot of attention
to that 9% uh and and of course because
of the uh the negativity bias you know
you may have 100 nice comments and then
there's three people who are like wow
this sucks yeah and you're like you know
you'll beat yourself up that day like
man why do these people not like this um
but you did you know you're you're
assigning less weight to those 97
comments that were positive but you're
also not thinking about the 90% of
people who didn't comment at all and
based on that breakdown right if if 97
comments are positive and three are
negative you can probably estimate that
that's probably roughly how those other
90% exactly yeah yeah yeah silent nice
comments yeah I saw this um yeah I read
this this uh this essay uh uh recently
about about a TV show uh in which the
executives were threatening to cancel it
uh because they had received and this
was I think in the 1980s it was a sitcom
and uh the executives were threatening
to cancel it because they received some
some angry emails or not or angry angry
snail mail from from the viewers so this
was the ' 80s and uh and the the the
showrunners were basically they drew
this analogy of like this is like you
know going going to a stadium of 100,000
people and two of them write a nasty
letter to you right that's the
equivalent right because we have X
number of million viewers and and you
got a couple of hundred mean letters
whereas the other million plus people
didn't write anything or maybe they're
writing positive things and so I think
yeah we that that that 1% R can sort of
helped us to
contextualize um sort of all of the
social phenomena that are going on
online I remember the general election a
few years ago where the Tory party won
won by the biggest landslide in a very
long time and the the red wall fell and
all the rest of this
stuff
uh and I remember
seeing stormy or Bugsy Malone and that
year's winner of Love Island and someone
else like like Daniel Radcliffe or
someone uh tweeting about how you know
we need to make sure that we get the
labor party in and I'll be voting labor
and you see all of these replies I like
oh oh my God look at this it's going to
be a total Landslide you know like
they've got Bugsy Malone has tweeted
about
it and um then it was the as far in the
opposite direction as it's ever been in
50 years yeah it's like you know the map
is not the terrain yeah and the internet
is not the real world and here's another
thing as well you know you've got the 1%
9% 90% but I think it's only around
about 10 to 15% of people in the UK have
a Twitter account yeah right right so
not only you not thinking about all of
the silent lurkers yeah you're not
thinking about all of the people who
aren't on Twitter that don't even know
that this is going on looking at it did
you hear the episode I did with Sam
Harris uh I I listened to clips of it
yeah cool so he comes up with this idea
called digital leprosy H this is just
awesome by him so he says um because
he's no longer online MH he's not
exposed to the potential ation and
online furors that he's a part of so
kind of in the same way as a leper may
be losing Limbs and digits and be
unaware that it's happening right he may
be being cancelled right now but because
he's not online he's unaware of the
cancellation that's occurring or the
whatever like he's somehow is is
trending again he's like I'm not on
Twitter and he's told his friends look
don't send me screenshots of what people
are saying about me on the internet so
he is able to just you know blissfully
move through his existence he called it
digital leprosy which I just thought was
like such a lovely idea evocative term
man that's good yeah yeah well yeah I
guess in that case it would depend on
what your what Your aims are I could
imagine so someone like Sam you know
he's uh he's an intellectual he has his
podcast and he probably it it wouldn't
help him to see all of the the nasty
comments but if you're I think it may be
a little bit more than uh like two out
of 100,000 or whatever at the moment as
well he's kind of popular to hate on the
internet yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's a good point but but I well for
other people if you're well I mean the
first thing that comes to mind would be
like a politician you would want to know
what's going on how people are reacting
to you yeah exactly sort of keep your
keep your finger on the pulse of uh your
constituents um there is a there is a uh
one of the one of the chapters in in
Robert Green's 40 Laws of Power where in
the book is about the attainment of
power of course so he writes that in in
those kinds of situations uh you
actually want to be more plugged in to
the Social Scene It it actually isn't
wise to withdraw uh because you'll end
up losing power you'll end up losing
influence interesting he also has a rule
about how aloofness is alluring though
uh which I think is interesting and it's
definitely true I was with uh Dan
Bilzerian last weekend and uh was
talking to him and he's kind of been
he's sort of absconded from the
permanently online Instagram you know
like tits and psychedelics existence
that people he kind of got famous for
and I was asking him about that and he
said well you know like he's kind of
going through a bit of a metamorphis at
the moment I think in in many regards um
which was very interesting to see and I
sort of dug into his psychology a lot
over dinner uh but also he was like from
a tactical perspective just not being
chronically online sucks in speculation
which is actually good for brand in some
ways people are like what is happening
and I think you remember this may have
been different for you given you're uh
slightly more chaotic than my upbringing
but each uh uh each summer when you
would leave school and come back you'd
always think oh here's my opportunity to
reinvent myself like I'm going to be the
sporty kid or I'm going to be the cool
kid or maybe that was just me um but I
kind of get the sense that if you're
going through a a a period of Rapid
change or rapid reflection or whatever
uh a little bit of um receding perhaps
from being so uh publicly AA this is why
monk mode I think for guys has become
such an important meme right that it's
this Retreat to focus on the three eyes
introspection isolation and um like
inner work or something else and um the
reason that it's so good I think is that
it allows people to like go away do the
Chrysalis thing and then try and emerge
as something new whilst not trying to
bring along all of the existing like I'm
trying to update one step at a time all
of the different changes it's like no no
no I get to go away and then come back
with a relatively Blank Slate or more
blank than it was and um yeah I think
this I think this something that yeah
yeah I think yeah it sort of depends on
what your aims are and especially when
you're when you're young and you're
still sort of uh uh trying to stabilize
your identity and figure out who you are
that having those moments of withdrawal
and reflection can can be very helpful
um yeah and and you know it's it's funny
those those the The Laws of Power a lot
of them do contradict each other and
green openly I've seen him he
acknowledges this but it is it's it's
based on context it's based on sort of
where you are in the life cycle and how
um how power is acquired in your sort of
local environment and and so on so so so
basically you know this isn't like a
one- siiz fits-all sort of checklist
it's more of a sort of holistic at all
times in all places it's in specific
times at specific places well you've
been looking at a lot of young male
syndrome recently I think this is going
to be one of the most important memes of
the coming decade and both of us have
been talking about it at least in part
for maybe like three or four years I
think online but it's picking up steam
what have you learned digging deeper
into the modern conception of young male
syndrome and how it sort of manifested
what have you learned yeah yeah well so
so yeah the young male syndrome this
constellation of traits that are
associated with uh a certain period of
time in young men's lives typically the
teens in the early 20s uh you know
heightened levels of risk-taking reduced
self-control and inhibition uh if you
look at rates of criminality for example
uh they tend to Peak at around age 19
and this is true regardless of uh
culture and Society sort of all across
the world in non-industrialized Hunter
gather communities and all the way up to
sort of wealthy and Rich societies that
it's the young men if you look at who's
committing the crime in that Society
it's it's inevitably going to be sort of
men age say roughly 15 to maybe 24 even
things like uh like like so this is just
in the US context likelihood of being
hospitalized for punching walls uh there
was a nice graph I saw uh and I and I
posted it online um of you know the sort
of the distribution of of of um young or
or men just men in general being
hospitalized for and it's all
concentrated again 15 to 24 it's like
you know 10-year-olds aren't being
hospitalized for punching walls and
neither are six-year-olds it's all that
sort of young male group and I'll admit
I've punched walls before yeah did you
see uh Alexander day posted quote
tweeted an image this morning that was a
mother asking how she could help her son
and it was just a photo of his bedroom
wall and this bedroom wall was just hole
after hole after hole and then the door
had a hole in it and it's like I mean it
looked like a sufficiently flimsy
American house that the hospitalization
risk was quite low but that the
decorating risk might be quite High yeah
yeah yeah that's uh in that case I mean
that yeah that that sounds like it would
require some some serious intervention
serious yeah intervention some serious
treatment what I find interesting is uh
especially for young men that's sort of
that this this is I think an expression
of the young male syndrome is when a
young man uh experiencing some sort of
uh usually like a minor injury and then
their immediate response is to lash out
so like I saw this with some of of my
friends where um you know like maybe uh
I know something simple like like they
accidentally uh poke themselves in the
hand or something and then their
immediate response is to punch something
so they hurt themselves and they're
pissed and then they punch something and
and I think that this is basically a a
misfiring of this kind of evolutionary
impulse of of if a if an intentional
agent hurts you it actually is uh
advantageous uh to to fight back
response right exactly so so if uh I
don't know like the cactus plant stabs
me you know maybe punching the wall is
unwise but if you do something to upset
me and then I immediately respond
physically that can actually be um an
Adaptive strategy so I think like that
is you know this is this is speculation
but this is what I think is going on
there because otherwise it doesn't make
sense right you're injured let me injure
let me break my hand now yeah it makes
no sense
so uh so yeah so the young male syndrome
yeah sort of reduce inhibition increased
risk-taking criminality uh risky driving
um you know if you look at uh who who's
arrested for drinking driving who uh
gets into the most auto accidents who is
the most likely to be killed simply
crossing the street yeah so so it's yeah
men are twice as likely to be killed
simply crossing the street as women um
so there are so many sort of different
different factors here and there was
actually one on on the seat belt point
there was an interesting study which
found that men are less likely to wear
seat belts when there's when they're
accompanied by a male passenger relative
to when they're sitting by themselves or
when they're sitting with a with a with
a woman what do you think that's saying
I think that is uh one possibility here
is uh is essentially the attempt to
Signal toughness uh that you know you of
course like there's a lot of interesting
work here and a lot of discussion and
and debate around this um because of
course men want a signal to women and we
want to signal that we're you know
strong and can acquire resources and all
those kinds of um sort of Bedrock uh um
findings in evolutionary psychology but
then we also want to impress other men
too you know you want to show that you
would be a you know in in the ancestral
context you want to show that you would
be good in a in a violent conflict
against a rival Coalition or if you're
uh big game hunting you want to show
that you're strong and so I think the
way that it might manifest itself in the
modern age is I don't need to wear a
seat belt you know I'm going to show my
friends and my mates like I don't need
to wear this like that two ton rocket
ship going towards me hasn't got we
both became fans of that David putt
study oh yeah that was able to predict
the uh number of sexual partners based
on not female ratings of attractiveness
of male faces but other male ratings of
toughness of the same male faces super
cool study that the women's
attractiveness rating had basically zero
predictive power but that the man's
toughness rating had like quite a good
bit of predictive power yeah was it you
that taught me or was it Dunbar that
taught me about um men's Street crossing
in the presence or without the presence
of women H that was probably done bar
right okay so this this this study is so
much fun so they got um crossing the
street is really interesting because
it's a relatively discreet variable you
have distance of vehicle from Street
crossing and then you have uh like the
presence or lack of presence of a female
and Men the diff difference in how close
the vehicles would get and men were
prepared to cross the street in the
presence of a woman was like a third of
what it was when there was no women
around like look at of this you know
Surplus Fitness that I have I'm going to
cross the street while this car is only
15 yards away from me or whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah all that I think yeah the
young male syndrome is yeah I think it
it sort of depends on the context but
yeah it is most likely to sort of be
expressed when you're trying to impress
women or when you're trying to impress a
men again so I don't think yeah it would
I don't think it would necessarily
impress young women uh you know that
you're driving without a seat belt right
and I think maybe on some level guys
understand that but with with with it
wouldn't NE it's not so much that you're
impress impressing your friend when you
put when you don't wear the seat belt is
that if you do you might be mocked or
made fun of or that what's you know are
you know what are you wearing a seat
belt for that kind of especially you
know like 19-year-old guys you know that
kind of thing um and so it's not so much
trying to look tough but just not to
look weak very interesting okay so but
young male syndrome specifically seems
to be uh worsened
amongst sexless
dispossessed rambunctious young guys
yeah Coalition together in small groups
to go and set on fire and push over
granny yeah yeah yeah and we yeah yeah
that's uh it's you know when when a
young man is isolated sort of by himself
there's only so much damage he can do
but it's sort of the the r the risk
becomes exponentially greater sort of as
that as as he sort of partners with
other men and they collaborate and start
to plan and so yeah this is a I mean so
so you had this this interesting term
about the the sedation male sedation
hypothesis it's in a it's in a a study
at the moment with bus and William
they're testing it interesting
interesting yeah I mean I'm just
thinking about cuz I remember when you
first told me about that something that
had come to mind is um you know I had
friends I mean this is you know sort of
back in the I don't know if people still
play this game World of Warcraft but I
remember I had a couple of friends who
like Lost Years of their life to this
game and they were like and they the way
that they spoke you know as you know
when you told me about this I thought
like yeah these young guys you know this
is you know 18 19 this was years ago but
they would say like all right you know I
got to I got to hop off the phone I'm
going on a raid you know I got a raid
scheduled you know like well you don't
have a raid scheduled you have you know
7 hours of sitting in your laptop chair
computer G exact but in his mind he's
like I'm going with my other internet
friends and we're going to go you know
raid this Castle or whatever they do in
this game and I could see that yeah this
is a sort of an expression of that or an
example of that of you know just young
guys who ordinarily might be out causing
trouble and instead they're just online
uh and that's how they do it you know I
saw this funny this funny post on
Twitter um and this guy you know he said
something about you know back in the day
if you were like a hyper curious young
man uh you know you you'd basically
start like uh trying to document the
like visible differences between the
mushrooms uh right around your house and
today what they do is like try to
collect all the Rings in a Sonic game
you know like
speedrun uh and so yeah I think the the
virtual world is sucking in a lot of a
lot of uh angry and aggressive men but
we may also be losing like that sort of
the pattern matching sort of
systematizing abely yeah well it's just
it's managed to hijack an awful lot of
the status seeking
coalitional curiosity adventurous
behavior that young men you know
throughout all of history has been kind
of acclaimed for you know you look at um
my favorite example of the solution for
young male syndrome was Portugal in the
1800s what did they do there they the
first son was allowed to there was an
imbalance in the sex ratio okay and they
knew that if son one married because he
was the oldest son but son two three and
four perhaps uh weren't permitted to
marry and there weren't enough women to
marry that this was going to cause
problems so they just put them on
gallion ships and said go you know
Pioneer the new world away you go so
they just they literally exported the
young male Problem by putting the men on
ships and giving them this sense of
adventure you know channeling their
aggression outward against either a new
world or or
political enemies or whatever it was and
uh yeah I think that there is still a
question Vincent came on the show mutual
friend came on and he's been researching
and he says you know every single time
that we have high rates of sexlessness
and blah blah blah we have an increase
in Associated violence and it's just at
the moment and someone may tell me that
I'm wrong but it doesn't seem to be
there in the data right we have incel
blackpill ideology there was this period
maybe about two years ago where uh they
were even uh donate
claimed to be a domestic Terror threat I
think uh in cells uh they were a
terrorist group right yeah I saw that
um where's like show me the violence
show me the uptick in the violence now
that's not to say there hasn't been an
uptick in murders and stuff but I think
a lot of that can be attributed to the
yeah exactly like the receding of police
from inner cities right um yeah yeah I
wonder if the so so on its face it seems
silly right that the insults is a
domestic Terror threat but I wonder if
they were just sort of if they were
actually familiar with the research on
the young male syndrome and the sort of
historical p i mean maybe I'm giving
them too much credit but but they
essentially they were sort of
anticipating the possibility and they're
just sort of getting out ahead of it and
saying well you have a lot of young
sexless angry young men and historically
that's been the you know a group that's
been dangerous so let's just designate
that label on them but I think yeah in
the Modern Age with with technology with
video games with porn with scrolling
phones I mean yeah I've seen sort of
research on uh what young men like
jobless young men do um and most of the
time they're scrolling their phones
playing computer games watching porn
overeating junk food you see Nicholas
abats work on that uh I haven't is this
this is related to the men without like
men not working or whatever it is
whatever it's called just awesome but
yeah it's like some insane percentage of
men are neats not in education
employment or training uh but Al our
Prime working age like I think it's 22
to 50 um and it's this unseen because
unemployment rates are relatively low in
America but hiding in that data is a
very unusual cohort of men who are
electing to be unemployed they're living
on uh social welfare in one form or
another or Andor still living at home
spending an insane amount of hours per
year playing uh video games and while
they're playing video games 50% of that
time is either on prescription
medication or whilst taking weed so you
just have a very it's like okay here's
the Big Data okay well what's that like
how's this constituted who are the
component people that make up this data
and you go hang on a second like what's
this chunk it's like I think it's like 8
million or 14 million men Prime working
age men electing to retreat from the
employment market now we put this
episode up and uh a lot of guys that are
maybe a part of this cohort are
tangential to this commented and you
know the sentiment very strongly was why
should I contribute to a world which
doesn't value me uh why am I going to
work to get a a 5 fo3
210b uh woman who's already gone through
two marriages and got four kids uh you
know just very despondent evidently guys
who don't see much future for themselves
and uh it was it was really eye
openening cuz largely the comments on
Modern wisdom tend to be you pretty
personal growthy agentic highly
Sovereign upwardly mobile Etc um but
this episode like blasted out of the
algorithm into the wider internet or
maybe it got shared on some forums or
whatever uh and it was very very
interesting uh and I got to see a you
know I got a window into into this world
and it didn't seem these guys didn't
seem very happy um they were maybe uh
comfortable in their nihilism uh but I
don't think that they were particularly
fulfilled I mean they may be comfortable
when they're young but there's I you
know I'd be curious whether sort of as
as we move forward um you know decade or
two decades later I mean it's one thing
to be a a neat when you're 19 or 23 but
when you're 43 or 51 and you're single
maybe you've never had a girlriend and
you've spent most of the last you know
several decades just playing video games
and and and swallowing in Collective
misery on forums and stuff yeah I think
there's I mean now in the Modern Age we
have so much Freedom you don't have to
work anymore you don't have I mean if
you don't want to if you live in a
modern Rich Society um you can collect
sort of extended unemployment or maybe
live with your parents or um find ways
to I mean you know very few people now
very few young men are sort of literally
starving or having to steal food to
survive and uh and now if you want to do
something difficult you have to make the
choice to do it rather than um sort of
uh uh be be pressured sort of by by
external factors I saw this I saw this
this Tik Tok video I'm not on Tik Tok
but people sometimes send these to me I
saw this one this this this uh this
young guy I think he was in the Army US
Army and he was just sort of walking
through his barracks and uh and he was
asking these these other these other
young young guys these young recruits uh
you know if you could talk to your
recruiter right now what would you say
and uh you know these you know these
other young guys were like I told him to
go himself or like God this sucks
why did I do this so on and so forth and
I'm watching this I'm like I know
exactly what he's talking about because
I was there I was you know i' had
enlisted I was in the Air Force and I
remember especially like the first two
years are just awful like once you get a
bit of rank and a bit of responsibility
like once you go through the training
purp stop eating yeah exactly then
you're like you know then you're okay
but the first couple of years really
suck and so I knew like these were all
very young guys they were still sleeping
in bunk beds and I would have said the
same thing you know I'm glad that Tik
Tok didn't exist back then but I'm
watching this and I'm thinking like
these guys don't understand right in in
5 years from now they're going to be
glad that they ate for however many
years and they did this they went
through this experience um and and I
think a lot of young a lot of young guys
won't even go that far like they won't
even the list which is fine you know
everyone has their own sort of make your
own choices but in that moment I
understood that like this sucks why did
I do this like this is awful and then
you go through it and you can sort of in
hindsight go back and say like it was it
was a character forming experience it
was good for me like I was an idiot when
I was 19 and I probably needed a bit of
that structure a bit of that discipline
I needed to have my ass kicked a little
bit and uh and I think yeah like you
don't but and and those guys volunteer
to do that right you have to choose to
do undergo that experience you've
already pre-selected for someone who's
got the agency to get moving yeah I had
this idea I had this idea about um uh
the the reason that victimhood culture
has become so widespread is because the
human systems demand for challenges has
outstripped our modern reality's ability
to deliver that right that we want we
just want something to push up against
and if we don't have real challenge we
will create imagined challenge for
ourselves and um yeah you know rampant
fragility and this kind of like soy
externalizing locus of control culture
that's going on at the moment it's so
interesting though that you've got this
barbell strategy where you know 50%
maybe more percent of the people are
young men happy to lean into the uh I've
learned a bit of behavioral genetics and
evolutionary psychology and and taken
the black pill in many regards because
I'm a genetic dead end but at the same
time you have the ascendancy of David
Goggins jocker willink Alex hosi you
know these guys who are all about doing
the hard thing overcoming the suck like
no one's coming to save you it's only
you that's going to get you etc etc so
you have this increasing sort of
Divergence between the two uh and I
think you know assortative mating which
is people of a Kind mating with people
of their kind right so Silicon Valley
135 IQ people with you know professional
tennis level skills having kids together
so you kind of have this genetic
splitting apart which also is going to
have a psychological uh like heritable
psychological Echo I suppose so the
conscientious people will have more
conscientious kids and so on and so
forth and then Melissa carne's new book
the two parent privilege is talking
about how those college educated people
who' got that predisposition again get
an even bigger Advantage so I think that
the Matthew effect of this right to
those who have everything more will be
given to those who have nothing more
will be taken is just going to continue
to spread and spread and spread yeah I
think I mean that's that's a distinct
possibility and it seems like in the
short term that is what's occurring I
mean I even read this oh man which book
was this uh it was a speculative
hypothesis about why there's a like sort
of pronounced levels of uh kids being
born on the Spectrum in Silicon Valley
and it's
because it's not necessarily because the
engineers and the program MERS
themselves are autistic but they may be
sort of sort of somewhere on the
Spectrum and then they partner with
someone who also shares some of those
genes and comorbidity exactly and then
they have well they have children and
then and then the child is sort of at a
at an heightened risk of of getting
autism uh but I think generally speaking
I mean I don't know if this is if this
is this could be interpreted as a white
pill or a black pill but I just read uh
this book The Son Also Rises by Gregory
Clark who's an economic historian uh
very well versed in the behavioral
genetics as well and essentially that
book he documents uh in various
societies essentially how uh social
status sort of loosely defined as sort
of wealth and influence and so on is
very sticky uh across generations and
essentially what he finds you know he he
he tracks surnames uh and finds that you
know I got intro to this guy from mataap
Poria he's going to come on oh yeah yeah
he's great yeah yeah yeah um and yeah
spoke with I spoke with Matt about about
um Gregory Gregory Clark's work as well
and essentially you know he he tracked
status not through so you know there's
there's there's this fear especially in
the modern era of assortive mating that
more and more women are going getting
educated and men are are dating educated
women and they're having children who
are educated and so on but what
essentially he finds is that when you
when you look at data from decades past
centuries past before uh women were sort
of educationally and economically
emancipated when they were still sort of
stuck in these rigid gender roles if if
you pair or if you look at the status of
of a given man interested in a woman and
then look at the status of the woman's
father there's like a very tight
correlation there so even though the
woman herself isn't um Highly Educated
or isn't working in a prestigious
occupation often she comes from a family
in which her father was and so one of
Clark's claims generally speaking in
this book is that people are very good
at sort of finding people who are
similar to themselves even if you don't
have the sort of external visible Badges
of of class or education or credential
how does that manifest if it's not the
external badges yeah well basically
people people cluster together in the
same clubs family friends
organizations um so so maybe uh you know
maybe the man didn't meet the woman in
the workplace the way that they would
now but maybe um you know his boss's
friend says hey I have a daughter who
you might get along with and even though
she isn't working she's you know the
daughter of the friend of the boss it's
like a social instantiation of the class
uh disposition yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean this is uh yeah this is interesting
to me I mean so so Scott Alexander did a
a long piece on on the Sor of meeting I
think earlier this year and he talked
about how there's surprisingly little um
uh sort of sort of matching across uh
sort of educational and class lines on
the things that you would expect on
things like like attractiveness for
example I think there's this especially
in the sort of like the red pill um
online spaces of you know men don't
really care about education they really
care about a you know how attractive a
woman is um and yet uh at least the the
data that I saw sort of uh curated by by
Scott Alexander is that you know it's
very rare for a highly educated man to
actually date the you know the the the
college drop out who uh theist Starbucks
exactly yeah or or if they do date the
Barista at Starbucks she has a college
degree and I think a mistake that we
might make you know I'm sort of
channeling Gregory Clark here is that
like oh he knew that she had a college
degree and that's why he was open to
dating her whereas I think Clark would
say actually they they they had a they
had some conversations together and
through that he could sort of tell that
they were maybe roughly in the same
class the same space her sort of uh uh
levels of curiosity and intellect and
all the sort of psychological attributes
uh they they matched along those lines
so you know even though she maybe Works
uh uh uh somewhere that doesn't require
a college degree she has one and she's
the kind of person who would get a
college predisposed prised and then they
sort of match along those lines the sort
of mating still holds I think yeah
there's there's so so again like is this
a white pill or a black pill it could be
a black pill because you know status is
sticking and it almost doesn't matter
what you do but on the other hand it's a
white pill and that like you know even
though we have all of these educational
and occupational Trends in the modern
world it doesn't actually it may not
actually change the sort of underlying
social and romantic dynamics that have
sort of with us for centuries more
stable yeah than we might think I think
there yeah I think it might I mean
you're look at you as like the poster
child for what was
it uh kids that grow up in is it single
parent homes are like 10 times more
likely to go to college than adopted
kids what was the stat no so so the stat
is it was on foster kids specifically um
so I did you know some of this research
as I was writing writing my book that'll
be out next year and then um I wrote
this essay that's uh that was in the
Free Press A couple of years ago which
basically um so in the US kids who are
uh raised in families in the bottom uh
socioeconomic quintile so the bottom 20%
essentially kids raised in poor families
uh roughly 11% of them graduate from
college which is pretty low because the
the the average rate in the US is around
35% so it's pretty low 11% versus 35%
but the amount the number uh or the
percentage of of foster kids in the US
who graduate from college is 3% and so
in other words a kid raised in a poor
family is four times more likely to
graduate from college than a foster kid
uh and so I used you know this is sort
of essentially to me sort of evidence
that instability and uh sort of
disorderly environment is uh is OB is
perhaps something that we should be
paying more attention to which obviously
has an effect but it may be something
that that deserves more attention than
we're giving it relative to sort of the
material factors did you dig into
Melissa con's new one have you read that
yeah I I just read it I finished it a
couple of weeks ago excellent book
excellent book yeah the two parent
privilege dude so I watched she's been
on the show anyone that hasn't seen that
can go back and listen to the episode I
did with Melissa she was great but I
mean she is you know as straight down
the line policy wonk DC pilled as you're
going to get right like she's like the
female Richard Reeves you know like
she's just there to do help do policy
and do the DC thing and and she's a
statistician demographer lady right
she's I I tried to push her on the
episode and was like so why is this
occurring like give me the implications
here infer for me what you think is the
underlying mechanism and she was very
reticent about trying to to work out
what's going on from a psychological
perspective and I thought wow that's
really uh that's a good signal that
she's not prepared to get out over what
she sees is her domain of expertise yeah
yeah I have this this is what I do and
she did it a little bit but she didn't
go too far and I was like that's a
really good signal but what I saw on the
internet before her book came out tons
and tons and tons of Articles saying you
know this is uh like hard right
Christian talking Point uh being
legitimated by cherry pick data you
haven't read the data the book's not out
yet yeah yeah and what I saw was her as
someone as far as I could see that if
you were to do political compass on her
would probably be like just left of
center uh and again very not prepared to
say things that she didn't understand
and didn't have data to back up and so
on and so forth but on the internet the
only people that weren't lambasting her
as being some sort of you know like
biger judgment Al that's telling
people that come from single parent
households that they shouldn't and what
so you're saying that women should stay
in an abusive relationship instead of uh
you know allowing their themselves and
their child to have a good stepparent
and blah blah blah like just all Straw
Men house
arguments and I saw the exact path that
many many people are taking which is
causing them to bend toward the right
because you go hang on a second I've put
this piece of workout which is
relatively dispassionate which is
actually it's the two par
privilege this is a championing of how
we can fix underprivileged kids which is
fundamentally a left-wing phenomenon
right it's class we're trying to fix the
class problem the only people that were
accepting of her or weren't like
accusing her of doing awful things were
the people that were center right and
further right yeah so what you see is
how somebody that has a left leaning uh
predisposition perhaps or just a
Centrist disposition gets nudged by
their treatment toward the go okay well
you guys like if if if you're not
going to accept me I'll happily like and
she I wish that I'd noticed this before
I spoke to because i' would Lov to have
asked her about
this but yeah like that's not I I can
completely see
how the tribalism of of both sides and
I'm sure that there's an equivalent
Dynamic on the right pushing people
toward the left that I don't see um but
the tribalism of the left and the Purity
spiral of the left and it
it's rapidity at judging people M to see
bigotry where there may not be some yeah
I can absolutely see how this is causing
more and more people to lean yeah in a
different direction yeah yeah I mean
yeah I saw I saw a lot of that uh sort
of the ad homonyms online and a lot of
the uh insults and derogatory comments
that were directed at her and I thought
yeah they were completely unfair the
book I mean the other thing is like the
book is is very dense but it's also um
you can read it in an afternoon I mean
she presents the data in a beautiful way
a very sort of straightforward way that
any sort of educated and curious person
can understand uh and it seems like yeah
most people just didn't even bother
flipping through it and and having a
look because she caveats multiple times
that this isn't a this isn't a book
about sort of s judging people or about
values it really is about um sort of
looking just sort of from a disp
dispassionate point of view what did the
data say about outcomes for kids and
various sort of family uh arrangements
so yeah I thought that was so strange I
mean yeah and she does stick close to
the I think generally speaking that's a
good idea when you're
making arguments that are unpopular that
you should stick very closely to the
data and not go too far ahead of your
skis there just because um you're going
to be held to a higher standard when you
say something that's that's unpopular um
there's that sort of can versus must
distinction uh sort of a classic finding
in Psychology about how when people are
uh predisposed to uh support a certain
point of view essentially they
implicitly ask themselves can I and and
then they come across a piece of
information that supports that point of
view they implicitly ask themselves can
I believe it and generally speaking the
answer will be yes I can believe that uh
and when they encounter something that
is at odds with that point of view they
implicitly ask themselves must I believe
it and if they find a reason if there
are any any flaws in that argument or
any any reason whatsoever why they can
discount it then they say oh I I don't
have to right doesn't doesn't this show
up was it you that taught me about how
this shows up in Twitter arguments where
when people are wanting somebody puts a
point on the internet that goes against
something that they believe and then
they go on Google and search for uh like
why such and such a thing is true uh and
they're just it's like you're not asking
for um is this thing true you're looking
for arguments that support your side
yeah so you're looking for a good
Barrister rather than an honest judge
yes right right right yeah you want um
you want some uh well you're looking for
arguments of course that sort of you
know the classic confirmation bias idea
you're looking for information you're
monitoring and and then you're sort of
overlooking anything that that might
make you feel uncomfortable or that
might call your beliefs into question
there was a really cool study I want to
say this was in the 9s um sort of along
this vein I mean it's it's a it's it's a
neat example because it's sort of
disconnected from politics you like I
think anyone can appreciate this which
is essentially what these researchers
did was they brought these participants
into the lab um and you know they they
told these participants you know they
showed them um this this jar and it was
really just water but they told them it
was this sort of chemical solution and
if you drop a strip of water into it so
in one condition they told the
participants to you drop the strip of
water into it um and it and it doesn't
change color it just sort of Remains the
Same white or whatever it was uh then
that means that you don't have this sort
of rare unique uh congenital disease if
you know you dip it in leave it in for a
few seconds pull it out stays the same
you're good to go and so they brought
some participants in and you know
basically they found you know parti jip
it in didn't change color they'd walk
right out in another condition they told
the participants um you know you dip the
strip into the piece of paper and if it
changes color then that means you're
good to go if it stays the same that
means you may potentially have this
congenital illness and in this case what
did the participants do they dipped the
strip into the water waited dipped it
back in waited took another strip dipped
it back in waited and then they started
to get nervous and essentially they were
going for that confirmation because what
what did they want to believe they
wanted to believe that they were healthy
and when they did not receive
information that supported that then
they started to to sort of you know
shuffle through and and and uh and try
to try to find ways to confirm that that
that belief we both came across the same
research that shows that Chads rather
than incels are the extreme misogynists
right dude I love this yeah yeah yeah I
think I saw uh William retweet that word
and that's got on my of course of course
he does of course he does anything
that's Pro insell yeah uh men with
higher levels of sex partners are more
likely to hold extreme misogynist views
which contradicts The incel Narrative
extreme misogyny correlates with status
seeking and dominance orientation both
of which also correlate with high levels
sex
partners yeah I thought that was an
absolutely fascinating study and it it
links up very nicely you know I I when I
was in in grad school I read um David
bus's evolutionary psychology textbook
cover to cover and one of the things he
points out there uh is is uh that you
know there's there's not much if any
research supporting what uh what's
referred to as the mate deprivation
hypothesis you know this idea so the
mate depression hypothesis is
essentially that you know young men who
are who are deprived of mates are more
likely to develop these sort of uh uh uh
misogynistic attitudes they're more
likely to uh coers women into sex or
more likely to commit sexual assault and
essentially uh all of the research that
I've seen indicates almost the reverse
of that and including the study here uh
which points in the same direction which
is that the men who are the most likely
to commit sexual coercion or assault are
also men who are the most likely to uh
to have consensual sex partners as well
wow um and yeah all of these things sort
of come together and correlate with
status seeking dominance orientation
extraversion um the probably I would
imagine narcissism as well and maybe
some of the other dark Triad traits of
being being particularly attractive uh
to women and I you know this is now you
know I'm I'm I'm more comfortable
speculating uh than May you're not even
the academy anymore say what well you
know I have a foot in but but but I'm
I'm comfortable sort of making this this
is just a hypothesis but I think that
most many Maybe most women would be
pretty reluctant to actually be sort of
alone in like like be in a situation in
in in which they could potentially be
alone and assaulted by the sort of
prototypical incel like you know the
sort of lonely unattractive isolated
angry
male right exactly like they would know
in advance like I don't need to be alone
with this guy there's something off
about him uh again the sort of
prototypical I'm not saying all incels
are like that but that sort of
archetypal image of of an incel whereas
um probably just just sort of you know
uh uh I think this this pretty intuitive
that that women would be more willing to
sort of be alone and and potentially be
in a risky situation with a man who is
attractive right and so just through the
sort of differentiating levels or
different differing levels of being
alone and exposure alone that um that
that assault would be more likely to
happen in one context than the other um
and so I think that may partially
explain some of those differences that
if women were alone with actual ins
as much as they're alone with you know
status seeking dominance Ori orientated
extroverts that maybe those the numbers
would be different but but generally
speaking I think that finding is
suggestive and then in my own personal
life I mean when I think about the guys
you spend your time alone with yeah well
that I spend yeah yeah and that I feel
ad yeah um but the guys that I know who
are
particularly you know at least
numerically successful I know you what
success mean in this context but just
have had a lot of sex partners they do
tend to be a little bit more glib a
little bit less um preoccupied with well
what does she think of me or you know or
or or um or sort of what traditional or
conventional or or hold sort of
benevolent sexist attitudes right it's
usually usually a little bit more you
know I guess on the positive it may
jokey or playful but then on the other
it can sort of dip into you know the
example that I so so I posted uh one of
these studies online and sort of
commented that um you know I think this
is easy to understand when you reverse
the genders you know if you think about
like like a woman who spends a lot of
time um attracting men I'm thinking
about someone like like a stripper for
example like I'm sure they have
extremely cynical attitudes about men
right uh whereas women like if you think
about a woman who doesn't really you
know maybe isn't very attractive or
hasn't had a boyfriend or hasn't had
that much experience around men they
probably have a little bit more sort of
I know maybe slightly more optimistic
views or at least um less less than
views Sadia Khan psychology psychology
lady she does like couples counseling
and stuff uh she gave me this really
interesting answer to the question uh
are hot girls more crazy right okay so
the classic the classic question like
finally Aristotle's got an answer um and
she said that the experience that hot
girls have of most
men Shades their view of all men because
the men that she spends her time around
are unbelievably pliable they cheat on
their partners with her they try to
shower her with gifts they say things
that they think she wants to hear
they're duplicitous so the reality
Distortion field of the beautiful
woman causes all of the men or many of
the male interactions on average to uh
group together to Clump together in a
way which doesn't show men in a
particularly good light right yeah how
cool is that as an idea like the
reality Distortion field of the hot girl
or something yeah that is it reminds me
of this this this interview I watched
years ago of uh Chris Rock and he said
basically being well I don't know if he
he said something along lines of being
an attractive woman is like being a
celebrity or being a celebrity is like
being an attractive woman where once you
reach a certain level of fame or
notoriety or recognition that people
react to you in a predictable way in a
way that that is often obnoxious or or
um you know try to give you free things
or try to try to court you or you know
they're looking for something from you
and uh yeah that is yeah where you're
only seeing a sort of you're only seeing
sort of one version of that person
whereas everyone else might see another
version and pre-selecting for the only
sort of people who are prepared to go up
to the hot girl in the first place yeah
I saw this with strippers uh and I would
imagine it maybe the same with only fans
girls as well a lot of the strippers
that I was friends with throughout my
20s when I was working in Nightlife had
very very jaded views of men MH because
they were seeing the Stag on his
bachelor party out in Newcastle you know
trying to get a off one of the
strippers that are in there right like
men at their worst selected for at their
worst around the women that are able to
you know cajo or coers or encourage them
to do a thing that's whatever uh and oh
that's how all men are there's this
really great segment uh on Rogan's show
years and years ago Tim one of Tim
Dylan's first appearances
and
Joe's I think Tim's talking about how
the LA comedy scene is very ruthless and
Joe has just moved to Austin and is
saying don't know what you're talking
about fantastic over there uh every time
that I go into a room everyone treats me
really great and blah and Tim Cuts in he
goes hold on one second like you do know
that you are Joe Rogan right like do you
like you bend reality around there's
this sphere that follows you where like
who the going to treat you like
right the biggest podcaster in the
world just walked in and um I spoke to
tuck Max about this over dinner a couple
of months ago it's so interesting um and
I was talking about
how I I I've noticed certain groups of
people treating me differently over the
last couple of years is status and and
Renown and wealth and whatever has has
changed and there is a reason now to be
nice perhaps or maybe there's not a
reason to be nice they don't even know
it but something happens they've heard
that's the guy with the podcast or
whatever so you just noticed that like
the average stranger interaction has
adjusted in some way maybe I'm just
super like charismatic or whatever I've
changed my confidence that totally could
be it too but my more um like highly
skeptical uh cynical view of it is like
people want something or whatever anyway
and um I was talking to Tucker about
this and he said uh to become rich or
famous as a man is to accept being uh a
resource to be extracted for from or an
object to be desired he said that um
women become objectified as soon as they
become uh you know like womanly you know
you're 13 years old and the boys in the
class now start to see that you've got
boobs and and then you become like 17 18
and the whole world objectifies you for
a while because your value is immediate
and upfront whereas you know this is a
red pill takeaway I guess that like uh
women are born with value men have to
create it um and it is unless you're
Brad Pit or you know somebody who is is
super good looking and has that upfront
um you have to achieve some degree of of
self-generated value in order for people
to treat you and to objectify you right
like no one's no one's just objectifying
the random dude in the street but if the
random dude in the street gets out of a
Bugatti maybe they are right oh what's
he got oh dude let me tell you let me
ask you about blah blah uh yeah to to
become an ex a resource to be extracted
from uh or an object to be desired that
was very interesting yeah yeah there's a
sort of a a positive feedback loop that
happens there too I think with with the
Bugatti example um so so you have this
uh prestigious material good and then
you step out of it and then suddenly you
know you have increased Social Capital
because people are drawn to you but I
think this happens even even within just
the r of Social Capital itself I mean
you know I I'll just use this this
personal example of you know I was I was
walking through an airport with some
friends and uh and then yeah it was
recognized a couple of different times
but you know so I I was with friends but
then they had friends who didn't really
know like they oh they kind of know that
I write and stuff but they don't really
and then I got recognized and suddenly
they became more interested in talking
to me and like oh what do you yeah what
exact tell me more about and so I think
it's like um you know you get recognized
once and then other people become
interested and then suddenly you can't
did I ever tell you that story when I
walked down Broadway with Peterson uh in
Nashville I don't think so uh we went
for dinner it was about two years ago
from now and I went for dinner with him
and there was that famous video of him
dancing with his wife and Ben Shapiro
was there in Nashville just a few years
ago oh I did see I saw it was the night
after that so he loved this bar and we
were going to go back to this bar and he
didn't have any of his security with him
uh so it was me Michaela Michaela's now
husband and Jordan and Michaela's
husband's like six foot4 kind kind of
dude so like he was like he's like a
tall guy or whatever uh but no security
and Jordan started walking down uh
Broadway like the street in Nashville
right it's where Kid Rocks Bar is and
Whiskey Row and all this stuff and they
on a weekend close it off I think they
close it off at both ends maybe they
don't but anyway it's
stacked someone notices Jordan Peterson
and then goes over to like get a photo
with him and shake his hand and hello
how are you and then other people notice
that other people are standing talking
to someone so a q forms to speak to
Jordan Peterson he's accumulating a tale
of humans as he walk like a
Comet right walking down Nash com yeah
honestly and uh I I remember thinking
like oh my God we were at the Young uh
delegates uh dinner drinks thing last
night at ARC here in London uh and sure
enough there was a a queue of people
like this is a conference of people
selected for a very like particular set
of interests and then we went to 150
person drinks thing which is selected
from within that group for people that
were invited to go to this thing and
even within that selected group of a
selected group the comet tale thing
existed again so um yeah that's almost
like a like a physical manifestation of
what you're talking about that's on
socially right people see they don't see
a physical CU but they see uh like a
social CU right like a CU they go oh
okay right and it's I would I would be
curious I mean maybe in the the example
of the 150 or or smaller group of of
selected people they probably are
familiar with Jordan it sounds like but
uh in the example of him walking down is
it Broadway the street of Nashville when
that tail formed what I would be curious
to know is probably many of those people
maybe most of them did know who Jordan
was but what I'm curious about are the
people who didn't know who he was but
just saw the tale let's get everyone's
following that guy I guess I'll get like
I guess he's famous let's go check this
out and now they're follow and so you
know so what percentage of those people
were were familiar with him too you know
there's these there are these classic
studies from uh from Milgram uh so most
people know mgrm through the um The
Obedience studies of you know the uh uh
he essentially tricked people into
shocking and and believing that they
were injuring someone or perhaps killing
them but there were these other studies
that mgram did and and and other social
psychologists you know this sort of
classic work back in the day of you know
he' just have people uh on like a
Manhattan Street and just have like four
or five research assistants look up at
the sky just like me you a couple other
people just look up at the sky like this
and then gradually what happened is
people would be walking by and they'd
see you know four people looking at
something and they'd stop and look up
too like what are they looking at and
then and then there suddenly this
massive crowd form of like suddenly you
have 40 people looking up at the sky and
no one knows what they're looking at
right everyone's trying to figure out
what those original four people right so
there's that sort of imitative you know
quality that you know which is which is
you know it's it's adaptive uh but it's
also you know can kind of misfire be
funny situations yeah being moderate is
a green flag you see this new one about
extremist views William shared the graph
of it I haven't seen this one but uh let
me get your take on this this is awesome
researchers pulled over a thousand
registered us voters aged 18 to 34 a
majority of both men and women consider
far rightism and Far leftism to be red
flags in a potential partner 76 % of
women and 59% of men consider
identifying as a Maga Republican to be a
major turnoff 64% of men and 55% of
women said they'd also swipe left on
someone identifying as a communist so
that was high number of women 76% for
Maga 64% of men for communist 55% of
women said that listening to Joe Rogan
was a red
flag about modern wisdom 35 that wasn't
on there 35% of men uh 41% of men said
the same for a woman being into
astrology okay uh 20% of women uh 33% of
men said red flag for they say black
lives matter 14% of women 53% of women
for they refuse to see the Barbie
movie uh 53% of women uh 58% of women
for they say there are only two genders
so more women concerned about the two
genders thing than the Barbie movie
interesting uh what that is but yeah
just overall it seems like um far
rightism far leftism uh being moderate
is a green flag basically like having
but that being said how is saying that
there are only two genders like an
extreme position how like I would have
thought that that would have been the
moderate position right like I guess it
depends yeah but the the B st's being
turned upside down but yet overall when
it comes to dating it seems like a
majority of both men and women consider
far rightism and Far Le ISM to be red
flags in a potential partner what what
what age group was this are these young
young 184 18 to okay yeah that makes a
lot yeah that makes sense I mean yeah I
mean you you've probably seen some of
these data too about sort of the
political Divergence of young men and
young women um which is really I mean
it's really interesting because uh a lot
of the the Press media will concentrate
on you know the supposed uh right-wing
radicalization of young men when
actually most of the sort of political
psychology survey data indicates the
reverse where men are young men are
slightly turning to right there sort of
a a slight turn whereas for young women
there's a sharp like a sharp rise in
young women identifying as left or far
left so it's actually the the women uh
who are being sort of uh uh radicalized
or or turning to a more extreme
Direction um yeah but we don't mind
about that one we know we don't need to
care about that yeah well I mean well so
I think like in in terms of like
violence and so forth right there's no
there's no young female syndrome you
know or or if there is one it would be
it would manifest itself differently the
female L house the fale at the long
house yeah um but yeah I mean in terms
of the sort of the classic threats of
terrorism and so forth I mean but but uh
yeah that's that's interesting I mean so
so some of those like yeah the the two
genders one that's interesting 58% of
women I found like that yeah there's
there's a sort of a a neat reversal
there of like Maga Republicans versus
Communists where most men I seemingly
okay with dating a a magga identifying
woman but women uh are more okay with
dating a communist identifying man
here's the thing right that it's not
apples for apples right like uh 35% of
men said that a woman listening to Joe
Rogan was a red flag but a man listening
to Joe Rogan and a woman listening to
Joe Rogan is not the same thing that's
true too yeah you know what I mean yeah
like there was one about uh owning a gun
that like some quite high percentage of
women said that owning a gun was a red
flag right in America yeah but a woman
owning a gun is not the same as a man
owning a gun M right and and the same
for listening to Joe Rogan and so on and
so forth so I it's it makes for very
interesting reading but I actually think
that like if a woman does listen to Joe
R there'll be some non-zero number of
men in there are like that's a like
that's a boy's show like why why like oh
maybe she's super disagreeable or maybe
she's like going to try and arm wrestle
me in bed or something like yeah yeah
yeah yeah I have I've heard this um you
know just just speaking with young guys
that uh you know they are to some extent
sort of bothered by these gender
differences in politics and how more and
more young women are sort of identifying
in in a more sort of sharp leftwing
Direction um but then they also sort of
lament that you know a lot of young
because you have to be you know to some
degree psychologically peculiar if
you're a young woman who is a sort of
right-wing person or or or identifying
openly as a conservative because you're
sort of going against the grain right
like you are an outlier in that sense
and that of often sort of coincides with
other things that young men are kind of
annoyed by and so it's like it's the
astrology one dude 41% of men said that
a woman being into astrology that one
was confusing to me I think like that's
fine you know that's like a very to me
like a feminine way of thinking you know
like I think it's you know I can't
remember who what who was it that said
was it they said uh um uh the big five
is astrology for men I've heard that for
evolutionary psychology evolutionary
psychology evolutionary psychology it's
astrology for men yeah but
well that's fine but they like you know
a lot of well a lot of men but but at
least in my experience more women are
interested in the mbti the Myers Briggs
that is I mean it's you know it's not
it's not completely astrology but it's
more like astrology than the big five I
had yeah it is I had a a Spencer
Greenberg on the show do you know
Spencer really interesting dude I think
I've seen some of his I got intro to him
from William mcll um just super
interesting guy mathematician but just
does science like I don't know what he's
funded by maybe himself but uh and he
did a huge breakdown of like predictive
power of uh Myers Briggs versus Big Five
versus other stuff versus other stuff
and uh Myers BRS is like I think it's
like 18% accurate basically on actual
predisposition of things but uh yeah it
is that that's astrology for astrology I
think uh what was that study about
higher female status and gender equality
being associated with the lower female
uh relative to male happiness and
relationship satisfaction and stuff like
that yeah this was a study I came across
I think it was published in
2015 uh which yeah essentially found
that that higher levels of wealth and
and sociopolitical equality among the
genders is associated with lower levels
of of relative happiness for women
compared to men and the researchers
speculate this may have something to do
with increasing levels of employment uh
the the pressure to obtain higher levels
of Education uh among women in
particular and that this is actually
sort of uh uh uh uh dampening women's
levels of happiness and to me this this
connects with another uh and this one is
you know this this classic finding of
the the Paradox of declining female
happiness which is essentially that
since the 1970s uh women's happiness
relative to to men's has declined so to
be clear everyone's so so relative to
the 1970s um everyone is less happy
today compared to the 1970s but in the
1970s men were actually happier uh no no
no sorry women were happier than men so
women had higher rates of happiness is
relative to men in the 1970s and people
generally were happier overall fast
forward to the present and uh things
have reversed men are now happier than
women although overall people report
being less happy um and so yeah that
that study that I pointed out that was
an interesting one to me because yeah I
mean the the message that a lot of young
people receive today is what are the
keys to happiness you know you you you
work hard you go you get a you go to
college you get a degree you get a
high-paying job you sort of Follow that
cookie cutter
track and what is the the purpose of all
of this um and it's you know I I I
suppose you most people say well they
want to be happy and so you go through
the education and employment route maybe
you go to law school after college you
sort of get the credentials you go
through the whatever the fellowships and
all these different programs and at the
end of the tunnel you're hoping that
you'll be happy uh and actually uh for
both men and women doesn't seem to be
working but for women in particular um
because they've had the sharpest decline
right cuz remember they were happier and
now they're you know so they exactly and
and so their uh uh diminishing happiness
has actually been sort of more
pronounced relative to men um the men H
the men's happiness being sort of higher
than women's is is interesting as well
and I wonder if that is almost sort of
uh the the reversal in some ways of
course they're less happy overall but
why would they be happier than women and
I wonder if that's to some degree
because they don't feel as much pressure
anymore the sort of um you know back in
the day men were sort of pressured more
to be earners and providers and so on
and there was a sort of a economic
pressure associated with that and now
that you don't really have to work I
mean we're seeing young men are sort of
dropping out of college they're dropping
out of higher education and employment
and at least in the short term depending
on how the survey questions are
presented if it's just you know how do
you feel generally or how do you feel
today or what have you I think a lot of
you guys might be like yeah I don't I
don't I didn't have to go to class given
the fact that men were previously less
happy and relative to then are now less
happy also it's just that really the the
change the big change here is the
that's I wonder whether um like the male
dissatisfaction with the uh gameful
employment state of seeking providing
thing was just baked in already it's
like oh okay like we we we already knew
this like Granddad was spit and sawdust
and he was unhappy and dad was spit and
sawdust and he was unhappy and I'm spit
and sord dust and I'm unhappy but there
is a little bit less pressure to do this
uh was that Candice Blake that did that
one uh the the the female happiness
study I don't recall the the the authors
of that one it was the Journal of
Happiness studies she definitely taught
me about either that or something
similar which is yeah that you know the
gender pay Gap positively predicts
relationship satisfaction oh I have seen
that yeah yeah I think yeah I read that
paper um which is you know
it's and it's it's funny because so it
predicts relationship satisfaction if
men earn more than women and then it
also there was there was a reversal of
this um I don't know if if if kace was a
study on this were different different
uh authors but they found that when when
women in marriages earn more than men
that this predicts higher rates of of of
arguments of verbal aggression on behalf
of the woman of just general
relationship higher rates of domestic
violence infidelity on the part of the
man as well men are more likely to cheat
when they earn less uh 50% increase in
the use of erectile dysfunction
medication when woman's the primary
bread winner I heard that too yeah
that's uh yeah that's pretty it's pretty
I mean it's it's grim but then you know
I I uh you know here's an anecdote I
remember when I was in undergrad and I
had this conversation it was uh you know
it was me and like this this group of of
women these female students and one of
them you know she was a pretty hardcore
feminist and she said that it should be
50/50 like 50% of women uh should be
working you know 50% of women like if
it's the case that 50% of women are
working 50% of women should be at home
and same for men you know if 50% of men
should be working 50% of men at home and
uh and then you know so then I was
basically just sitting back like I was
not going to get entangled in this but
then some of the other women were saying
you know okay so you know but like would
you actually be like okay with that like
your husband's staying at home I don't
really know whatever and then and then
finally I decided to to jump in and I
said like you know speaking to to this
this this young feminist woman I said
yeah can like so I know that you plan on
going to law school you're very smart
you're going to be very successful like
how would you feel like your husband is
at home I don't know changing diapers
and taking Tak care of the kids and
you're at you know you're at a a
prestigious law firm with a bunch of
high-powered attorneys like how would
that you know you think you'd be happy
in that situation and her response was
um wow I I got like I think I just felt
A tingle when you said High powerered
attorneys like I got really excited when
you said that that's basically her
reaction wow and it was half joking but
half serious and all all of the women
laughed I laughed too it it was you know
it was a good response but like I think
you know that there was an element of
seriousness there right that like when
you you know when she's sort of
fantasizing about like yeah rubbing
shoulders with all of these you know
high-powered successful at the top of
their game and then you got your husband
at home and I think it's just it's
different right like it's men and women
are different we're attracted to
different things yeah it's interesting
to think about uh the potential pressure
that uh may come along for the ride with
you are supposed to be gainfully
employed and have your education and be
able to sort this sort of stuff um
that's something I the
not just the going to work not just the
getting up early and and the hours of
sleep and all the rest of it but kind of
the
psychosocial interpretation of being a
person that is status striving and
playing the game of the water cooler and
all of that stuff kind of doesn't really
factor into the discussion about you
know is it in conscientiousness is it a
part of your hard work like your grit
and your resilience and your desire for
all this stuff but there's just a like a
soup that comes along for the ride is a
part of being a person who's playing the
employment and the education game and
having to go out for drinks on an
evening and it smoo up to the boss and
all that sort of stuff and uh no one
really talks about that because that's
part of work right like that comes along
for the ride as a part of work but no
one ever talks about that and it's like
okay like it's the classic do you want
to be a CEO woman do you really want to
do 80-hour weeks and do you really want
to do that and it's like do you really
want to play this game for 20 years m of
sucking up to people and and
having to do the social network
manipulation and deafness and all this
so that being said given uh women's sort
of predisposition and and ability to be
a little bit more like uh subtle with
with their cues and their emotional
intelligence and stuff I actually
imagine that on that side they might be
predisposed to it well but as it seems
uh their well-being may suffer more than
men's
despite their capacity for doing it
being uh as good or greater yeah I mean
I almost wonder if it's uh it's sort of
the reversal of what we were speaking
about earlier about you know young men
who who don't want to do hard things but
then once they do them they find that
they enjoy them and they appreciate it
whereas in this in this context you know
maybe maybe some women think oh if I
follow this this track and get get a lot
of education and go to you know it'll
make me happy then once you get there
it's actually not it's not as satisfying
as you would have hoped um it's actually
worse than you expected and I think a
lot of I know people like this actually
as I as I'm speaking and thinking about
it I know a lot of people who you know
they think that once they get there um
it's they have this certain image of
what it's going to be like and actually
yeah working 70 80 90 hours a week um
and even you know they are doing well
financially they are making money they
are buying all the material Goods that
they thought they wanted um wearing you
know amazing clothes nice apartment in
the right parts of the city and so on um
but they just don't have time to enjoy
it because they're always on the clock
non-stop working weekends no time to
appreciate um
you know but there I think there is an
element of the sort of social signaling
where you know the almost at some point
the only satisfaction they really have
is the fact that they can tell people
about these goods and and their job and
how prestigious it is I was teaching you
last night about my theory of uh Surplus
mate value uh so Chris Bumstead Mr
Olympia classic physique Champion three
or four times comes on the podcast and
tells this story about how he cries on
the bathroom floor a few weeks before
he's about to win the Mr Olympia uh
because he's super stressed with all
stuff going on in his life and the
pressure of having to win and all the
rest of it and his like girlfriend sort
of holds this dude that's like 260 PBS
presumably just holds the top of his
head uh in his arm in her arms and says
like it's okay and blah blah blah uh but
this was the guy that is the living
instantiation of the gigachad meme right
like he is the dude that is over the
peaky blinders quote like the Killian
Murphy quote from py blinders is he
speaks over the top and it's just Chris
bumpster just looking like mean and
stoic like he's the sigma male meme
that's been used on Tik Tok right like
he's Mr Sigma male and I brought up to
him this kind
of odd uh irony that the guy that is the
face of the sigma male meme the stoic
you know emotionless just grit and grind
and go through it thing was heavily
dependent on his girlfriend in order to
be able to go and achieve the next part
of his you know trajectory right uh and
one of the things that interestingly got
brought up in the comments was well yeah
he can do that because he is Mr Olympia
and it got me thinking about Surplus
mate value so if there's a sufficient
disparity in mate value uh not to say
that Chris is Chris's m is like a smoke
show super smart I'm pretty sure she
went to like like multiple college
degrees plus like World Fitness
competitor herself in her own rights but
it's like there is just
a ladder that you can continue to climb
if you go and be world champion in
anything and basically that Chris had so
much Surplus mate value in his
relationship uh that he could get away
with withdrawing from this bank account
he's allowed to cry but if the uh if
you're not the world champion right like
maybe the guy that comes 20th maybe he's
unable to do that um and if he if he did
cry on the floor that would dip him
below and the girlfriend would see him
for the vulnerable that he is and leave
um but yeah just kind of an
unfalsifiable uh well I mean I mean it's
it's it seems like an illustration of
counter signaling essentially right like
when you're I mean the the whole idea of
counter signaling is like once you reach
a certain point uh in in a status domain
you uh you can you you can actually
behave the same way as someone very low
on the status domain would behave and it
actually increases your status even more
uh and so example I like to use is uh
this classic work from from Jeffrey
Miller and his colleagues about uh self
deating humor that if you're a very high
status person and you're holding a
meeting or you're just in a social
setting and you make fun of yourself a
little bit um people actually it it
ingratiates you it sort of uh increases
their admiration of you that oh he's
just a humble guy he's making fun of
himself but if you're a low man on the
totem pole and you start making
self-deprecating jokes people don't want
to be around you they're like oh who's
this you know this this guy who uh
doesn't like himself very much or just
it just it hits people the wrong way um
and then yeah our mutual friend Rory
Sutherland likes to use the riding the
bicycle on the way to work example which
we we mentioned this last night too
about how if the uh you know if the the
guy who works at Pizza Hut rides his
bike to work is because he can't afford
a car but if the CEO rides the bike to
work it's because he cares about his
health or he cares about the environment
or he's just a you know he's just a
conscientious guy or you know there's
there we we and it makes us like him
more that he's just you know he's riding
his bike he doesn't you know he doesn't
have to drive the fancy car uh it makes
us like him even more and I think yeah
there's something there about that
that's sort of the counter signaling
element here and I think you can see it
in in in a lot of different walks of
life um just like how how much
self-promotion people do there was a um
a classic paper called too good for
school um one of the early papers on the
counter signaling um uh sort of research
area and this was about so this was I
want to say in the early 2000s where
they asked uh or what they did was they
gathered um s syllabi from college
professors and found syi the the
syllabus is that what the plural the
plural of syllabus dear God okay um and
so they GED these from various
institutions and rank ordered them and
essentially found that the the more
prestigious the institution uh the less
likely the professor was to use their
title on the syllabus so if you're you
know if you're at some fancy IV League
school they would just say I'm whatever
Bob Smith but if you're sort of mid tier
or lower down it's you know doctor so
and so or Professor so and
soever all the degrees everything and
then they also called the so this was
back when people still had answering
machines and so they called the offices
of these professors
and found that Rob Henderson PhD
MSC canab all whereas at um at the the
the higher ranked universities right so
it's exactly the same yeah yeah this hey
yeah yeah Bob call me later whatever
whereas yeah the lower tier it's yeah Dr
so and so you know this office of this
department and just all of their
credentials and I I think we're now
seeing this to some degree in like the
uh the social media space now or in like
how how much self-promotion people do if
you're an established author you can
maybe make one or two announcements but
if you're still sort of struggling and
still trying to make it you have to do a
lot more self-promotion and but there's
a reversal of this where if you um so so
there was there was another paper when
it was something like uh when when
disclosing good news goes wrong
something along these lines where if
you're a very high status person doing
very well in your life and you do a lot
of self-promo uh and or or if you do a
lot of sort of um uh uh counter signal
people don't like it uh and so uh an
example that I've given is uh so like a
first-time author uh if your book does
very well and you write this long post
on social media you know I want to thank
all of you for following me on this
journey blah blah blah blah blah but if
a super famous wellestablished author
does the same thing it comes across as a
little bit go as a little bit like we
already knew you were going to do well
like you don't have to play this like
mock humility so I've thought about this
from a like a a storytelling perspective
especially over the last six years that
um going back and talking about when I
ruptured my achilles and set up a
special kind of stand so that I could do
it with my foot elevated in a boot I
remember those days we we had the
FaceTime and I'm like is that your foot
yeah not attached to my the rest of my
leg
um that that's that's kind of cool to to
track that Journey so you know for the
people that are on any kind of uh
trajectory with whether it be content
creation or a business or something like
that I think that there's an awful lot
of value of saying the things as they
happen of kind of showing the times
one of Alex alosi's biggest regrets in
life is that he didn't track the
times more because he's now worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and he
lives in this nice Penthouse and he can
retrospectively tell people about the
times but it's not the same as
showing them right and when you get
presuming that all of your plans go well
and you end up in the place that you
want to end up in when you get there
it's going to be way more difficult for
you to try and tell people about the non
Ivory Tower that you used to live in
yeah so I think that tracking tracking
your journey as best you can and you
know getting the posts out there or
writing about the times that have been
rough or things like that writing about
the challenges not only is it I think a
a useful tool for yourself to remind
yourself to go back and read or or watch
or whatever and see oh I went through a
period that I had to be resilient that
means that if I face similar challenge
in future I can also be resilient but
also it's a good like way marker in the
ground of like here here I was this is
kind of evidence skin in the game of how
life has been at least at some
points yeah yeah yeah that's yeah I mean
yeah I like I like that example though
and if you especially like I've seen
these cases of people who are very
successful and they they don't really
talk about the struggle until they're
already very successful and then once
they start talking about the journey
people don't really take it as seriously
is like well why are we just now hearing
about this or why haven't you talked
about this before I'm not sure I believe
this uh or you just sort of whatever
like like uh embellishing this to to
make the journey more interesting and
yeah I think there is there is value to
sort of tracking it along the way
and to yeah to to sort of reflect and
and I think it's it's also just like an
inspiring message too to other people
who are also struggling very early in
their in their careers or in their in
their lives um I think your I think your
book's going to do this
I'm really super excited I'm aware that
it wasn't supposed to be like you know
you too dispossessed human can become go
through the US Air Force and
Yale and you know all that stuff uh but
I I really think you know like reading
it reading early versions of the of the
manuscript I was like hell like
this is you know it's kind of like the
anti-black pill message like the guy who
kept on just getting kicked in the face
by life ends up kind of succeeding at
the end of of it I'm super excited for
it to come out yeah that wasn't the
intention but I but I have yeah heard
heard similar sort of feedback a friend
of mine who who joined the Navy um and
he was yeah he had just gotten out of
basic training and he was still eating
sort of early in in in his his
military career and yeah he read an
early manuscript and he was like yeah
this was this was great like this is
exactly what I needed in this moment cuz
I was just feeling so so awful and like
realizing God just put one foot in front
of the other just keep trying keep
taking shots and uh and yeah it'll it'll
you know hopefully you know work out as
as long as you sort of have your mindset
right and your priorities in order um
yeah man it's uh can people pre-order
that yet listed it's up so so yeah I
mean you know we can talk about it it's
fine it's it's coming back on you're
coming back on for the book so don't we
will it's up for it's up for pre-order
um I'll do everyone needs to go and
pre-order Rob's Buck right now I want to
shove this down the throat of the
culture thanks man thanks yeah yeah it's
um yeah and it has a bit of both I think
there's something for everyone I mean
there's a lot of sort of first-person
narrative driven stuff but then there's
also sort of sociological analysis and a
lot of sort of there stuff on on status
on um how we evaluate other people and
those kinds of things sort of work their
way and especially uh in the later
chapters of the book I I do this thing
where I sort of write each chapter from
the perspective of myself at that age um
but yeah as I sort of enter adulthood
and become a sort of more Curious and
reflective person I S you you know you
can sort of see the way that my mind I
guess sort of develops and the way I
start to think about things so yeah man
yeah I'm excited for it too and uh yeah
I'm pum for it to come out and the cover
is cool it's you as a kid riding a a
bike down the street uh you taught me
about this bow Meister idea about why
ovulation might be concealed in women
and I've got a counter like
hypothesis as well so what what was the
what's that idea that you learned from
bow Meister about ovulation right so
this was a a chapter uh this it was a
speculative chapter from from Roy Bal
Meister this eminent psychologist um
where essentially the idea here is that
so women have concealed ovulation right
you can't necessarily tell when they're
ovulating the way that you you know you
you you Vis very visibly can with other
great apes with chimpanzees and so forth
and so the speculative idea is that uh
it so so a lot of evolutionary
researchers have suggested that this is
you know maybe concealed ovulation is to
conceal from men right like so that men
don't necessarily know when the woman's
ovulating or you know whether whether to
sort of reduce the risk of sexual
coercion or to um sort of obscure
paternity uncertainty or all of those
kinds of things where as this
speculative chapter um posits that it's
actually uh to
conceal uh ovulation from themselves so
that women don't know because back you
know you know this is you know vastly
oversimplifying but back when women
started to be or human beings in general
started to become sort of
self-reflective and introspective and
and fully conscious and women could
suddenly tell oh when when I'm ovulating
I'm more likely to get pregnant they
could visibly see it then they would be
less likely to have sex and and in order
to um to essentially sidestep the
burdens of pregnancy because pregnancy
was extremely risky and uh become aw as
a woman you become aware of your own
menstrual cycle and avoid particular
periods appropriately and so the idea
here is that eventually uh only the
women who uh had concealed ovulation
were the ones to reproduce and then
gradually over time all women uh had had
obscured uh ovulation and and this was
essentially uh a way to to sort of
prevent women from from uh s acting
their their own possibility of pregnancy
and then uh yeah and some of the some of
those uh those those um excerpts that I
sent you there was a nice line from
Leslie Nome in this book that just came
out a couple of years ago called The
Story of Us which is a nice sort of
sweeping updated overview of human
evolution and essentially you know what
she writes she and her her co-author
they write that um you know historically
there may have been women who avoided
the burdens of pregnancy but those women
are not our ancestors right it was the
the the women who did under undergo this
this very difficult challenging and
dangerous experience and those those
were the ones so I thought those two
those two findings neatly duvail but I'm
curious to hear what's sort of I'm
pretty sure that it was Roy that taught
me about this one as well no it might it
might have been Candice Blake that
um other women are if if a woman while
she's ovulating or about to ovulate is
put under intense social and physical
stress it can cause the ovulation to
misfire
uh so women who are under real
significant stress it messes up the
menstrual cycle but many women that are
listening to this may know that their
menstrual cycle kind of if they're super
stressed at work or they're studying for
exams or whatever like the stuff gets
squirrly right like guys might struggle
to get an erection if they're super
stressed women might might their
menstrual cycle can go all over uh and
one of the arguments is that concealed
ovulation stops other women in your
tribe from with
you while they know that you're
potentially fertile yeah yeah okay well
so I I think like that so so these
hypothesis are not necessarily mutually
exclusive they all work together the
pair bonding thing like if you don't
know when you're ovulating if you don't
know when you're fertile it means you
need to have sex more frequently with
your partner which increases the pair
bond which actually means that husband
is going to stick around or that father
is going to stick around with woman in
order to be able to raise child yeah
yeah yeah I think there yeah so so in it
may require all of those different um
external phenomena to to produce that
outcome right like one of those alone
might not be enough where you know if if
it had only been the the concealing
ovulation from themselves maybe we would
still have you know some some percentage
of women who were visibly uh ovulating
and others who aren't but it may require
all of those different um Trends working
together to produce the situation in
which uh uh women are no longer sort of
visible when they're when or the
ovulation is no longer visible uh among
women so so yeah I mean this is uh I
think yeah this is this is sort of
a often this this obstacle people kind
of run into or this trap that we we
think like it can only be one or the
other but this yeah I don't think this
is necessar reason many many things
right I mean evolution is complicated
and intricate and so many things are
going on I think um concealed ovulation
given that it's super rare in the animal
kingdom I think as well so yeah uh
concealed ovulation is one of these
things that appears to just trigger a
whole host of doesn't matter which of
these hypotheses are correct uh there
are so many benefits right from an
evolutionary perspective and just
trigger all of these different things
you take 10% of them you're like it's a
pretty good deal it's pretty works
pretty well yeah uh what's that um
Solomon's Paradox that you you were
teaching me about what's that yeah so
Solomon's Paradox is so it's a finding
in in Psychology but it's named after
the the biblical King Solomon who had a
reputation
for being the wise King and there was
this this adage that arose uh uh that if
you have any issues you should ask King
Solomon and famously most people know
the King Solomon story of the the two
women who claimed uh uh that they were
the mother of the baby and then he um
you know kind of kind of uh sneakily
said okay well we're just going to cut
the baby in half and he knew that if we
you know he knew that if he did this
that the that the actual mother would
step forth and say The other woman can
have it and that that and that's how he
you know so so that's how he sort of
resoled this issue but it's a paradox or
they they they they assigned this label
the Solomon Paradox because King Solomon
himself in his personal life was
actually not very wise so he was wise
for other people but in his personal
life um you know he he he made a lot of
mistakes as a king he um he uh was was
not a particularly good father to his
son and his son actually grew up to be a
tyrant and and actually very bad King
because he had sort of uh uh mismanaged
his own parenting and so in Psychology
the Solomon's Paradox is that that
people can be be very wise for other
people's social problems but are often
less than wise for their own and so
there was a recent meta analysis that
just came out uh various studies looking
at the Solomon Paradox are people sort
of wiser when reasoning about you know
so they you know they'd bring people in
people who had recently gone through a
breakup for example and sort of ask them
well what do you plan to do and so on
and so forth and then they would bring
in um other people either strangers or
the participants friends or PE you know
peers of theirs and say well what do you
think this person should do in that
situation and and found and they found
various ways to sort of uh uh measure
this of of how to how to sort of um
measure wise decision making and found
that uh you know that social distance
actually actually helps it's the peer or
the stranger who can say Okay so this
person has just been betrayed by their
friend or they're just going through a
breakup or they're having some
difficulty in their social lives well
here's probably the best way to go and
uh the idea here seems to be yeah when
you're sort of emotionally entangled
it's hard to sort of act rationally it's
hard to act in a way that um you that
that that will benefit both you and and
and maybe the other party as well and so
as I was reading this I think you know
it's a really interesting finding in and
of itself but then I also I also wonder
so so I'll actually give an example of
this uh so there was a there was an
interesting study on on economic games
and so there's this game called um uh
the the ultimatum game uh in behavioral
economics and uh the simple version of
the game is that so imagine you and I
are playing the ultimatum game and the
researcher gives me
and says you can give some amount to
Chris and if he accepts the amount then
both of you walk away with the money and
so I'm under this you know the I I I I
have to deliberate and think okay so how
much do I have to offer Chris of my 10
he knows I you you know I have 10 uh so
you know I have 10 how much do I have to
offer you to say that was a fair deal
and we both walk away and what the
researchers find consistently is you
have to offer at least 30% um I would
have said 30% that felt about right yeah
and same yeah when I first like oh 30
yeah that sounds fair um any anymore it
would feel like unrealistic but any less
would feel unfair um and so that's what
they consistently find is around 30% um
but they've done different versions of
this game where you're playing on behalf
of someone else so so it's actually it's
it's um economically irrational to take
anything um uh to to to to decline any
amount greater than zero essentially you
yeah you should take anything right
because you know one is better than zero
um so what they find is that when you
have someone play on behalf of someone
else in the ultimatum game um so I'm
playing for a friend whatever um or
you're playing on have a friend that
people will accept Anya greater than
zero because they can step back and not
get so okay well is it fair is it not
fair it's okay so my friend either walks
away with nothing or they walk away with
$1 or $2 or whatever it happens to be um
and so so I found that finding the
Solomon's Paradox interesting because I
wonder if there's something if if this
can be applied more broadly to what's
going on with young people you've seen
some of these data about young people
having fewer friends fewer social
contacts less likely to be in
relationships less time uh in actual
physical social spaces and this the
solon's Paradox indicates that it's
actually helpful to have social contacts
and to have friends to talk your
problems through with so if I'm having
an issue and I've done this before I'm
like you know I someone you know I'm
thinking about uh making a decision in
my career or something I'll call you
I'll call someone and say hey what are
your thoughts on this and that can sort
of help me to contextualize and you'll
see things that I don't see and so forth
um but if you're a young person uh and
you don't have many people around you
that so so you're already unhappy
because you don't have very many friends
but then without the friends and people
you can communicate with to talk your
problems through with um in in in your
life whether it's in your career or
other other social domains romantic
relationships and so forth you become
even less happy because now you're
making unwise decisions you know and so
there's this sort of negative feedback
cycle that may few people to show you
your blind spots exactly and and to sort
of list out the options that you could
take that you aren't seeing Or List out
the uh the negative outcomes that could
occur if you make the the decision that
you're leaning toward um and so yeah
over time this may actually be
exacerbating it's not just about
loneliness it's also about the sort of
Solomon's Paradox and making more unwise
decisions in your life right yeah this
sort of recursive isolationist
decisionmaking which is suboptimal
compared with if you were so not only
would you have the support network I
would feel better but on top of that I
would also be making better decisions
which Downstream from that would lead me
to have a better life presumably
including maybe a better life where I
have more friends around me yeah yeah
yeah
Chris did you ever watch this show Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire yeah yeah so I
watched a I watched a couple of seasons
of like the new one this was during the
lockdown couple Seasons a couple yeah
lockdown man you know I got to do
something yeah is that a World of
Warcraft well I was playing in the
background right so i' put on you know
cuz I used to watch the show as a kid I
put on the back it was almost like a
comfort thing you know lock down and one
thing that I noticed was um I don't know
like they changed you know they used to
have these lifelines one of the
lifelines in this like updated version
or the whatever the covid lockdown
version was that they would bring their
smart friend along and that was a
Lifeline like theyd bring their smart
friend they'd be sitting in the back uh
and if they wanted to use a Lifeline
they'd turn around and ask their smart
friend what phone a friend was to be I
wonder if they did that because of like
Google or something you know so if you
phone a friend the friend can just look
it up online but now if they have it
right behind them they can't look up
online what the answer is and I was
watching this and I and I thought to
myself like yeah if you like if you
don't have any friends you know what I
mean or what do you do like who do you
bring along and I think you can sort of
apply that to your life more broadly
like it's you know you're in the who
wants to be million game you bring your
smart friend along but you know life
isn't Who Wants To Be A Millionaire but
life is a series of making difficult
decisions and if you can't phone a
friend and say hey what do you think
like the game becomes harder for you and
also if you do get accepted to Who Wants
To Be A Millionaire yeah you're not
going to have the friend to bring along
with you specifically for that situation
right as well you're missing out
potentially on a million dollars that's
a million dollars that you could have
had yeah I um I think there's definitely
something sort of recursive going on
here
and it's like the that in Citadel thing
that you taught me about which I just
can't unsee that Isaiah bin idea of if
you cannot get what you want you must
teach yourself to want what you can get
you Retreat from the Fateful ills of the
world into this inner Citadel like um if
you struggle to lose weight just declare
that weight has no bearing on health and
that you know like body Size Doesn't
impact attractiveness or if you struggle
to hold down a job say the all jobs of
for suckers and turned to a life of
crime or if you struggle to make
relationships work say you monogamy is
ancestrally unwise and I'm going to
become a polyamorous like like polycule
type person um and I do think that
there's an equivalent here the like
black pill Sigma male cope um and I
don't think that there's an equivalent
for women right there's not an
isolationist like retreat from the world
equivalent for women which I guess
suggests that the social networks uh
tend to be a little bit more sticky than
men's uh yeah yeah yeah I mean dbar
wrote this book on on the psychology of
friendship and that was one of the
points that he made that women are sort
of better at staying in touch reaching
out and organizing Gatherings and and
it's what is it the um I don't know if
he uses this term but uh it's sort of
face Toof face versus
shoulder-to-shoulder that when men have
friends do things together can't
unsee it I've spoken about this on the
show before but for the people that
haven't heard it um next time that
you're at a party any sort of gathering
look at the angle of the feet of women
talking to women and of men talking to
men women will talk to women 180 degre
they'll be face to face whereas men the
average is 120° so it's like blading
slight angle yeah yeah yeah yeah um and
I mean this shows up once you see that
you can't not see it and it's a rule
that works across so many different
things the men's sheds initiative in
Australia did you see that I have not
seen this they uh men it was an
initiative by the Australian government
I think uh to try and improve men's
mental health they realized that getting
men to sit down in a room and talk like
this about their problems didn't work so
what they did is they built sheds that
men came to and then the men would bring
like I've got this knacked lawn mower
and everyone needs to help fix it so how
are men talking they're talking whilst
their front brain is focused on this
thing that's in front and they are
shoulder Tosh shoulder not face to face
they're literally in a circle and
everyone's like right you you've got the
good drill and he's got the good spanner
and I've got the hammer or whatever and
let's fix this thing and god dude me and
the misses were not getting on well and
before you know it it's a therapy
session mediated by this lawn
mower right they have the the the
pretense of repairing the lawn mower but
they need that right they're required if
you just put them in the shed with no
lawn mower and they're just standing in
a circle it's yeah that's yeah so yeah
then that was yeah the face to face
versus shoulder-to-shoulder about um
yeah women will talk and communicate
with one another whereas men will sort
of they need a reason to sort of do an
activity together and and then
communicate and discuss their feels some
of my best some of my best conversations
are during pickle ball warm-ups oh yeah
just dinking just gently dinking the
ball everyone know all of the pickle
ball Pros out there know that you start
off very close to the net and you play
the game within the kitchen and then you
step back a little bit and you P sort of
like a mid-level game and then you step
to the Baseline and sometimes that
warm-up when you're close to the net and
in the midlevel game will go for 30 45
minutes with me and one especially if
it's singles less time if it's doubles
uh but if it's singles it's just you and
your friend he's like dude work's
getting a bit stressful or this thing's
happening and before you know it you're
deep in conversation in fact we did this
once at South Austin Recreation Center
uh me and my friend and there was some
guy that was s on the side uh and my
friend that I was talking to podcaster
as well and I think he was going through
some going through some something to do
with his life and we were just talking
and talking and talking and I realized
that we must have been doing this for
like at least 20 minutes and it's kind
of bad form to hog a court for a while
especially if you're not playing a game
because when you're playing a game and
somebody wins the winner stays on and
the next person Cycles in and I realized
that this dude had been s maybe sort of
like 50s kind of guy uh like very
typical pickle ball kind of player and
uh I realized that we'd been just
warming up for like 20 minutes again bad
form um the game will maybe take around
about 10 minutes or so something like
that and uh I think I turned and said
something like oh dude like I didn't
realize that you were waiting I was kind
of engrossed in this warmup and we'll
we'll we'll get a game going and he's
like to be honest that was a really
compelling conversation uh and I
remember thinking wow like the male
requirement for raction from emotional
communication is so strong that I can
play like a full warm-up for a sport
whilst doing it Yeah you sort of lose
track of of time I think yeah I mean the
the the sex differences in friendship I
think are there's there's another sort
of pattern that occurs where in breakups
men don't only lose their their female
partner but a lot of their friends
because it's the woman who's sort of
maintaining the or they'll sort of nudge
the man to say like hey have you talked
to your friend in a while you should
shoot him attack or see how he's doing
or what have you and uh it's hard to
it's hard to keep that up um for a lot
of men right because it doesn't come
naturally for them the way that it does
for women and they sort of Monitor and
you know there's obviously like sort of
evolutionarily adaptive reasons for this
that uh you know men are you know more
Expendable and sort of less preoccupied
with staying plugged in and survival and
all those kinds of things whereas women
are pretty good at sort of mon to tune
up the Alo parenting pool exactly the
same way that women do yeah and uh and
so yeah we see this uh yeah a lot of the
people in general report having fewer
friends but this is especially
pronounced for for for a lot of young
men um which is yeah I mean I've seen
you and I've seen some other sort of
recommend you know there are a lot of
ways like if you're if you're a woman
and you want to make friends there's one
way to do it but I think if you're a man
like getting involved in sports or
something some kind of activity like
that's the way to do it it's not just
like oh I'm going to try to make this
person into my friend it's like hey do
you want to like go play catch or do you
want to go think about some of your
friends you know we've got mutual
friends that you've been to a university
with with to studies with and if you're
both a part of a project for a brief
amount of time the male friendship
deepens so rapidly you know my ex-
business partner that I ran nightlife
stuff with for 15 years decade and a
half groomsman at his wedding uh you
know like phenomenal guy very formative
for me sat next to him in my first ever
seminar and became a business partner
there and then and we still great
friends I catch up with them every time
I go back to the UK but I'd be lying if
I said the depth of our friendship
hadn't diminished because we were longer
working toward a shared Mission whereas
uh editor Dean uh per he's a perfect
example so we brought on a new guy our
YouTube strategist and um since he's got
brought in the uh pace of friendship
deepening oh yeah has it's just been so
rapid because you're not just bonding
with somebody that you like like you
selected them to work for the company
because you would get on with them and
you think that you share your values but
because I spend 5 hours a week grappling
with with titles and thumbnails and what
who who who should we book on the show
and how am I going to sort this
schedule out and then he'll travel and
we'll sleep in some shitty hotel and you
know all of that moving toward a shared
Mission I think for men just and genders
it's more than it's like brothers more
than friends right you know it's almost
like for Warfare in a in a regard
solving a problem together right you're
solving a problem everyone needs a lawn
mower yeah yeah everyone needs a lawn
mower to fix yeah yeah that's what yeah
that's what put I mean it's a yeah
having having that sh and so so one
thing I'd be curious about with with men
and women because I know that there's
there's various studies sort of
indicating that there is this sort of
turnover rate this sort of friendship
halflife where supposedly I mean I've
seen different different stats different
studies on this some some say seven
years some say 10 years where roughly
half of your friendship pool turns over
every seven years or every 10 years you
lose half and they get replaced by
another group I wonder if this is more
likely to be the case for men than women
simply because of that sort of uh the
the the the way that problem solving
facilitates friendships and once you've
solved the problem once you've written
the book or once you've done the task or
then you sort of move on you whatever in
the case of academics you write you know
you write your chapters in your papers
together or you do your research studies
and then it's like okay moving on and
you sort of loose touch and so I wonder
if there is that sort of gender divide
in Friendship turnover as well yeah I
don't know that though yeah Rob
Henderson ladies and gentlemen Rob it's
just so much fun to catch up with you
I'm glad to get to do our first one in
person I love it as well uh you'll be
back on in February when's the Bookout
dates February 20th February 20th 3 days
before my birthday what a lovely
birthday treat uh so you'll be back on
when you come through Austin where
should people go they want to read more
of the stuff that you write I love your
substack I only subscrib to I think four
or five and they're all EX modern wisdom
guests uh where should people go
substack Twitter all that stuff yeah uh
substack robk henderson.com Twitter robk
Henderson um easy to find so look me up
and I'll be there hell yeah thanks Rob
thanks Chris thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Rob you will love my f- length
conversation with one of the best
behavioral economists on the planet Rory
Sutherland go
on give it a watch